The answer is that
the first two are in NP.
Graph connectivity can be solved in
polynomial time via depth-first search,
no certificate necessary.
This problem is in P, so
it's definitely in NP.
Does a graph have a set of k
vertices with no edges between?
Well, given the right k vertices,
we can verify this by checking
order k squared edges in the graph.
The certificate just needs
to give us this information.
This last problem is not decidable,
as we've seen before, and
hence it simply can't be in NP.
Note that there are decidable
questions that are not in NP too.
The easiest one to articulate,
given what we've covered so
far, is deciding if a non-deterministic
Turing machine will halt after k steps,
where k is encoded in binary.
Unfortunately, the proof is
beyond the scope of this course.
But it's worth knowing
that such problems exist.